we have apologies from councillor
jefferson councillor kettle
councillor shenton
and councillor junit thank you very much
thank you mr chairman page 3
minute number 53 halfway down the page
uh councillor richard
our ward member for snitterfield has
been spelt hampton lucy
i'm sure
to be fair hampton lucy is within his
ward but he sits for snitterfield
[Music]
i'll use fewer words rather than lots of
words i'm presuming everyone's read
the report
the synopsis of this is that uh hit by
covid
um
district have got the district council
got to support hospitality some way and
help help the recovery there's dmo
review in a couple of years time
we currently give shakespeare's england
75 000 a year we want to
aid the recovery by upping that to 100
000 with various conditions in place so
that residents can feel confident that
they're getting value for money
um
and that there are five recommendations
um that the two-year additional funding
package for shakespeare's england be
approved for the period first of
september 2022 to the 31st of august
2024
on the basis and now i'm sure you've
read all those five points
thank you councillor jennings any
questions thoughts observations
chancellor harvey
just to say we we did discuss this
before in uh cabinet forum um i just
want to make the point that this is not
restricted this
support for shakespeare's england is not
simply stratford-focused
stratford-based this is money which is
intended to support
the
activities of shakespeare's england
throughout the district and is intended
to be as much benefit for the outlying
um
market towns of ulster ships and
southern et cetera as as it is for
structured so i hope that
those who are watching this and going to
write in the local newspaper
that they do take the point that this is
not stratford looking after stratford
this is stratfor district looking after
stratford district
thank you council harvard your point is
well made councillor
just
parker
pick up on what councillor harvey said
do we know how many viewers we've got
this afternoon
no but i'm sure that we can we can get
that information for cabinet members
should they wish to follow their viewing
figures
for future reference thank you
counselor
cargill
thank you chair
picking up the point i was going to make
a similar
observation
um i've got no problems at all with the
funding i think it's essential to come
out of the the pandemic etc however uh i
notice in the on the websites of
shakespeare's england the the the first
listing will effectively be free but is
that it is that all that the the the the
rainbow centers are going to get out of
this or is there more than that
if you can suddenly find me another 100
grand from down the back of the sofa i'm
sure we could
thank you uh mr keford
just come back on that point if it made
so
yes they they get the website listing
but that sort of opens the door to
uh full engagement with shakespeare's
england and that so
um hopefully it's
it's it's an opportunity and it's it's
really uh trying to spread that
opportunity across the district
thank you that looks like all councillor
jennings are you going to move your
recommendation um sorry are you going to
move your recommendation yes i am
can i have a second to please
cancel the bar cap
all those in favor
that's unanimous thank you very much
kavanagh
moving on to the next item of the agenda
which is
going back to his papers
performance
21 22 year end report councillor
jennings
again this is a snapshot in time
um as we're coming out of a pandemic
and obviously we have more data coming
in all the time but uh the
recommendation here
is uh
one to note the performance achieved
during april 21 to march 22
in year two of the council plan and to
note performance against key performance
indicator targets
thanks to councillor jennings councillor
parry
thank you chair um i'd just like to
record my thanks to the management team
and the staff for all the hard work that
they have done
particularly over the last 12 months in
achieving a lot of the the target set
under very difficult and challenging
circumstances and i think um as a
district council we're very fortunate to
have such a strong team and hard-working
staff thank you thank you councillor
para if we can ensure that's noted as
thanks from the cabinet for the
performance there councillor harvey
and thank you chairman uh i don't
uh demure from what council perry has
just said
and at the same time i wonder if i could
put
the deputy chief executive on the spot
somewhat
of course
there are 11
items
where there are kpos i'm on
appendix
4 first page
top of the page
31 indicators 11 are off target and i
quite accept that we've we're suffering
from covid or
the implications of kovid but i would
really appreciate
mr perks's
opinion if he would identify for me
the
three
indicators which are off target which he
is most concerned about
mr platts could offer something on
council tax while you look for other
bits and pieces
uh thank you that would be helpful um i
haven't prepared an answer for this as
you've probably noticed
um
obviously the indicators that would give
me most calls for concern are things
like sort of the home choice plus and
anything that sort of delays sort of
giving
valuable services on onto our customers
but if mr platts would like to interject
on the council tax it would be welcome
to do that thank you
it does worry me in terms of the council
tax collection
and it has done really since the
pandemic kicked in
because um i think it's fair to say that
trying to collect council tax
is more difficult now than it was two
years ago and is going to get even more
difficult in the coming year so if
you're asking which ones worry me
i'll go with how to try and collect
council tax and keep the income flowing
for the council simply because with the
cost of living crisis the fuel costs and
everything that are going up people are
going to have to make decisions
and i think our job will definitely
become harder in terms of that
collection rate and trying to maintain
that collection rate on an ongoing basis
so that's just that was my view council
harvey not tony so but just started off
with that
councilor barker
yeah i can care on that one in terms of
what's coming in but uh i am really
concerned about home choice plus
um the
length of time it's taking
not to just determine them but to
complete them and also the there appears
to be an issue of how long people have
to wait before they can even talk to
someone about home choice plus but do
not fear
mr platts and others are all over this
like a rash
we will be reforming and choice plus
probably this week
thank you councillor barker my fears are
suitably allayed councillor paris
thank you chair i just wanted to
reassure council harvey with regarding
to the
under target performance for some of the
other planning applications just to
highlight
that the householder team
not only have been
under
in terms of recruitment because
of the recruitment for freeze they were
five people missing or five people that
they five people down on their normal
numbers plus we currently have the
householder team
actually handling 70 applications per
person per caseload at the moment when
normally they're 40 to 50
small applications and this reflects the
increase of households not wishing to
move but perhaps
have a small extension for the use of
homeworking so we do have a situation at
the moment where the planning
applications
on some on the householder ones are
slightly under target but this reflects
shortage in the team
and the high numbers per case officer i
hope that helps
harvey two points to make one is trivial
really um i was in a butcher's shop in
shipston this morning
and i asked i took the opportunity to
ask the butcher how trade was and he
said it was awful and i asked him why he
thought that was the case
and he said people are just not spending
their money
they're either saving for something or
what they say
not saving for holidays they're saving
for the electricity bill or the gas bill
whatever so i echo your concern about
raising council tax and creating it um
i think the discussion i was not trying
in asking my question i was not trying
to catch anybody out um
but i do think that the discussion that
we've had points to
an improvement which could be making the
way we report on
um performance
and i think it would be helpful to me i
i suspect it might be helpful to others
if if the report was augmented with
every time it's presented these are the
top three issues that are causing its
concern whether it's
uh housing issue collecting tax or
whether it's staff shortages or whatever
because
i think it would be helpful if the
management team could interpret these
for us to say where is operationally
where is the shoe pinching in a way in
which
members of cabinet may not be able to
appreciate i think that would be helpful
it would be helpful to me i suspect it
might be helpful to others it's not
meant it's not it's not intended as a
fault finding it's a it's a it's
intended as a suggestion which would
help help us in
appreciate where the operational shoe is
pinching
thank you counselor javier cancelogenics
just to be clear on that so
what you're suggesting is that perhaps
when we get these lists of 11 we sit
around we sit there as a cabinet discuss
it find out what we regard as the most
important and then propose it that way
or not or you want i think what is being
proposed and i think there is some merit
in it in the sense of it helps
engage the senior management team
with the cabinet in understanding
not just what the indicators say but
what they're telling us about the health
of the organization and the health of
the performance of all services is that
they come to us with what are the three
things that are giving us as a senior
management team sleepless nights
and they won't necessarily be the same
three things all the time and it may not
be that their performance indicators
that are going the wrong way they may be
performance indicators that are okay at
the moment however
further down the track we can foresee
and i think if if that enables us to
move from
purely recording and observing
performance indicators to having a more
in-depth understanding of what that's
telling us about the health of the
organization then i would suggest that
for any cabinet that is a worthwhile
exercise and i think perhaps the deputy
chief executive could take that back
through senior management team uh i
don't think any of us are looking for a
whole raft of new reporting i think what
we're looking for by if i take your
point correctly and i'm looking for nods
around cabinet table is
some some view from senior management
team what is this telling us and where
are the pinch points and it enables
everybody to start thinking further
ahead than the next cabinet meeting or
the next performance management report
with that are we all comfortable with
the recommendations councillor jennings
do you have a second of your
recommendation
counselor parry all those
in favor
you very much members
next item is
part c issues arising from overview and
scrutiny committees councillor crump
welcome
thank you mr chairman um
right hopefully our tribe is brief um an
interesting challenging meeting on
on friday
um which i've
for several reasons but um
i'll go through the headlines um
hopefully once i've got my computer
ready because i've has been too clever
and it didn't work
right um
[Music]
three items to discuss the tuscan finish
group
about
the lessons learned review following the
termination of the proposed merger
between ourselves and what district
um the terms of reference would mainly
agreed
but asked some sticking points about the
independent chair
of the suspect influenced group and i
believe mr buckland is uh going to be
speaking to
mr grafton as mr buckland was
substituting for mr perks who
who managed to speak to buffer instead
um probably a wise decision to get
admitted um there was concern about a
a former member of cabin after form a
current member of irsc uh
applying to be on the group
um
and despite uh my best efforts um
the the remaining people on the on the
committee um
wanted a review of the membership of the
tuscan finish group so it was agreed
that
the two main part is the dems and
conservative groups would review their
membership of the tuscan finnish group
i might if i might just interject there
i'm
this is councillor wally hoggins
is that correct
she's is she the only former cabinet
member on osc
no
oh castle cargill
i'm sorry i was because i was thinking
in terms of
involvement in the decision-making pro
process i understand i followed that now
because i couldn't quite follow why that
wasn't
trying to be subtle um but obviously
subtlety's wasted on me
just cut to the chase all right so um
there was um
i felt that having an ex-member of
cabinet
on the tuscan british group would make
the process easier
because you would bow to question that
person about the thought process at the
time
and that's only being one member of the
committee and there would be no
undue influence of the committee's
decision of the task unfinished
decision but
other members at committee um but we're
in disagreement and
um i was over it so um it was far that
we would go back to our groups to come
up with
membership
i think council the park
group thank you councillor barker
um
i had a
whatsapp conversation with one of my
colleagues here councillor jennings
during osc
not knowing precisely what was going on
because i couldn't watch it but um
my suggestion was and i don't know and
mr wolfton might be able to answer this
is what if there's a disagreement about
who chairs it what about the indep an
independent person of one of our
independent
persons
i think i don't know whether that works
okay as i as i understand it and thank
you for your note uh cancer trump there
is a conversation to be had between the
chief exec on his return from leave
because he was part of the conversation
whereas mr perks was not and mr grafton
unless that there's some conversation
already taken place
yeah i had had a conversation with him
and given him certain advice and he'll
be taking it up next week
okay so i think in terms of the task and
finish group we leave that in advance
until the chief executives
return i think you're just looking at
your other uh points um
you've points here about uh
shakespeare's england and its work and
its effectiveness i think probably
before councillor jennings jumps in on
that
i think it is
the overview and scrutiny committee
needs to understand that there is a
package of support that has been
provided we've just agreed to
shakespeare's england and a set of key
performance indicators have been agreed
and it will be those key performance
indicators that shakespeare's england
will be measured on in terms of
scrutinizing its performance
i know comments here about how it works
or otherwise for small business but for
this particular period of time where
we're then going to be reviewing funding
for shakespeare's england i think we
need to be absolutely clear that
shakespeare's england uh have a package
where they have agreed to a certain set
of performance
management indicators that's correct
isn't it councillor jennings uh and that
will be what they'll be expected to be
measured upon and scrutinized on uh
because that's part of the package uh so
i i've sort of make that comment as an
fyi counselor
thank you mr um yeah the other issue
that the other point we we felt we
needed to emphasize that
the role of um
the members themselves need to ensure
their own 10 councils and parish
councils were engaged with
shakespeare's england so we've we've got
a corporate responsibility to do that
ourselves um it shouldn't be just one
way so i think that that came out of
the actual presentation as well so that
was really effective so um yeah it was
um on the whole it was a pretty positive
um
discussion
um
moving on slightly quickly to
the performance
indicators uh there was a couple
there that perhaps would be good to get
some information back um there was a
comment about cp
3
b not cp
um
the uh
about including all ten centers when
forming any plans and that was that was
a given
and then i think it was cp5a to do with
open space
uh and that related to resource issues
which seemed to be a common point um you
know
there was concern about resources and
there was also concern about
scrutiny
wanting too much
um
because of the resource implications and
pressure on staff who as we know there's
been i think there was a mention here of
the five staff being shortened in one
area so we were concerned about how much
we're putting on offices
i think it's about sweating the big
stuff really councillor crump um
you know focus on the big issues that
are going to make or the issue is going
to make a big difference
um you know i think what uh whilst i
know we
question about an open space policy i
think it's it's working effectively in
the sense of a particularly local local
town and parish councils engaging really
closely about trying to take on open
space so yeah that would be my
observation is
in times where we're
under under some strain as an
organization we should be focusing on
where we can make big ticket
improvements in the first instance
anybody any other comments on uh on
overview and scrutiny
thank you very much indeed
thank you
so part d cabinet committee's nothing
party on block items
um the cabinet work program
climate change panel or
noted any comments and part f
other matters urgent business i have no
item of urgent business that's been
brought to my attention
i see nobody else bringing any urgent
business to the table
and that concludes the meeting thank you
very much members
thank you
are we still alive
is